j'ai réalisé un peu trop tard que dans
la communication homme-femme moi un peu
naïvement moi j'écoutais les mots
une erreur de débutant ça
il faut pas écouter les mots il faut
écouter le ton qui a derrière combien de
fois ça m'est arrivé moi j'arrive chez
moi et moi je sais pas que ce jour-là
elle elle a choisi de me détester
pour moi on est mercredi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
j'ai commencé l'écriture du spectacle je
crois le jour où j'étais au restaurant
et que comme dessert je suis vraiment
vieilli j'ai commandé une boule de glace
rhum raisin
et là ma femme Marianne
et je me suis dit et puis après j'ai
fait un créneau et j'y arrivais pas et
je me suis dit attendez baisser la
musique
[Rires]
dans la bagnole
c'est pas possible
super Hélène